Hôm Thông Mi đơn anh trong ngày 1,5 cho rằng,
Bộ Quay nè chứ không phải nha,
đang làm trận tiếng trên đàn đường một thoại thuận hoa bên,
nhằm chấm rất khu sức độ kéo dài gần 1 năm,
quan điểm đi ngược lại là trường của nhiều đồng minh chó ông.
Cú thể chung của phòng bánh với Ró Tơ dạ nhà chắng,
tổng thống trong nổi,
tổng thống ngave là đi mi步 chiến đả sẵn sản kết thúc trứng sự,
trong khi tổng thống của Quay nè,
bố lối đi miệ trời lệ sĩ tạo xa sâu dự.
khi được hỏi visa có nỗ lực đàn phán sống Mỹ giận sách chưa đặt cái quả,
ông châm trả lối ngắm khóc,
bánh đây, nằm bờ phía kia,
phát biểu của tổng thống trong đường đưa ra chỉ một ngày,
sau khi ngàn nèo lập trường tương tự tại lưu quốc,
tại của họp vụ đồng bán,
đại sứ tương trực ngà và sĩ,
nế bình tría cám buộc, uống khuy ra,
càng trở các nỗ lực hoa mình,
và càng báo,
mắt cơ và sẽ tụng giả quý sổn đồn bằng biển pháp của dựng.
Nếu kia không chức nhận các điều kiện đàn phán,
mà ngà chó là thực tế.
Tất của đàn phán thân đây tập trung và báo đàn mán ninh chủ quay nè hậu xung đồn.
Trong đòo, các bạn sẽ tình được chó là thúc đẩy kia,
chức nhận từ bảo hùng đồn bà.
Tuy nhiên,
ông thống Jelensky nhiều lần khẩn đệng,
uống quay nè không thể nhận bộ lãnh thồ,
theo hiện pháp nước này.
Ông trong trường biết,
có thể gặp ông Jelensky bên lệ gì đàn kinh tệ thế giới tại đã vô s,
nhưng chưa sách nhận kế hoạch cuộc thiệt.